[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
sin documentos un migrante está
prácticamente varado en su comunidad de
acogida y los trámites para conseguirlos
suelen ser largos y complicados en
españa por ejemplo la dificultad para
lograr una cita para diligencias de
extranjería a través de las vías
normales es una queja habitual desde
hace años la pandemia aumentó el
problema y el ministerio de interior-
reaccionó pero conseguir fecha para
registrar huellas dactilares y obtener
la tarjeta de identidad de un extranjero
es una tarea casi imposible
veamos a continuación algunos casos en
el reportaje de laura campo y arme el
expositor esta comisaría como decenas de
otras en madrid mantiene un flujo
constante de inmigrantes a la espera
para hacer trámites de extranjería
muchos son latinoamericanos que deciden
presentarse porque vía web no es posible
un problema al que se enfrenta este
colombiano que desea permanecer en el
anonimato
en una hora entró 23 veces mirando a
decir la página de carga mucha demora
para los casos que verdaderamente son
prioritarios
una parte importante de los 800.000
latinos viviendo en españa ha tenido que
pasar por eso en septiembre el mexicano
benjamín necesito una cita para obtener
la nacionalidad española nos muestra
como aún ahora no es opción obtener
alguna de podemos saber que no hay
ninguna cita para el trámite que quieras
y en cualquier comisaría de todo madrid
como veis no hay como todos los rubros
que escasean tienen un mercado negro los
trámites de extranjería no son la
excepción benjamín encontró en redes
sociales como comprar una cita por hasta
200 euros
tuve que buscar a alguien que me hiciera
el favor de buscar por mí pasaron dos
semanas hasta que esta persona me dijo
he encontrado la cita la tienes este día
y me ha cobrado 40 euros france24
consultó al gobierno español sobre el
tema y no respondió lo que sí se conoce
es que ha impulsado medidas como el
refuerzo de atención al público y las
aperturas de unidades sin embargo no han
sido suficiente para mejorar la atención
en otras áreas
así lo confirma esta abogada
especializada para adquirir el dni
excita siempre eso no pasa para las
puestas de huellas para extranjeros no
tienen no pueden acceder a las citas
todo el día en todo momento cuando es un
servicio público ese sistema de citas
previas no puede soportar la demanda y
la llegada de inmigrantes el año pasado
el número de extranjeros en españa
aumentó en 150 mil personas el gobierno
mexicano informó que concedería miles de
visas humanitarias a los migrantes que
viajaron en caravanas y eeuu con el
objetivo de disolver la marcha sin
embargo hacerse con uno de los permisos
no es fácil la secretaria del interior
de méxico proyecta que al menos 130 mil
personas solicitaron asilo o el estatus
de protección para fin de año
este estadio dejó por unos días de
acoger a deportistas para convertirse en
una oficina temporal de emigración todos
ellos esperaron a que las autoridades
revisaran sus casos lo que pedían eran
documentos que les permitieran
movilizarse sin problema por mexico
nosotros
en este documento para
[Música]
en llamas tuvo que acaba de me llamó
para méxico misma nada y
[Música]
entonces yo quiero saber
otros en cambio buscaban una de las
visas humanitarias prometidas por el
gobierno que le permitiría emplearse y
por qué no quedarse en el país y
abandonar su camino hacia eeuu una
alternativa ante lo difícil que
significa llegar al norte
llamame
la mamá del bebé
me siento muy comprometido como la
dejamos
porque tengo muy buenas amistades
mexicanas han atendido muy bien y
ya se volvió imposible llegar a eeuu
para que se aguante imposible sino que
se nos ha vuelto difícil mucho que no
tenemos posibilidades
pero no tenemos el apoyo de gobiernos
amigos
en estos momentos una visa humanitaria
y si bien el anuncio de la entrega de
visas humanitarias es un alivio para
muchos denuncian que los trámites para
conseguir los documentos son bastante
engorrosos nos demoran los trámites para
poder la residencia para poner una pista
humanitaria lo que queremos una visa
humanitaria y eso lo que queremos seguir
transitando libremente que no seamos
porque no igual nos sacan en algún papel
la coors que si yo llega en migración
nos ve por allí mal meten preso muchos
de nosotros por nada nosotros no somos
delincuentes somos personas que como
saben venimos de países donde la
economía donde la política está mermando
la población hemos tenido que salir de
nuestros países para poder sobrevivir el
pasado mes de octubre los funcionarios
de inmigración de méxico informaron que
las visas humanitarias serían entregadas
a mujeres embarazadas y niños
también se beneficiarían personas con
discapacidad y otros con solicitudes de
asilo en curso
las diferentes formas de identificación
les permite a los migrantes pertenecer
al país que los acoge al final la
documentación es una cuestión de doble
vía que le concede ciertos derechos y
permisos a los extranjeros pero también
deberes para con la nación a la que
llegaron hasta aquí inmigrantes de
france24 los invitamos a comentar en
nuestras redes sociales con el hashtag
migrantes f24 sigan con más información
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]